suppose we ask it to repeat the string
five question marks
hyphen and then five more question marks
another hyphen
oh my god it worked oh that was only
four question marks I screwed up do you
see what I mean how it's just like this
very very specific string what does it
say when it doesn't screw up if you give
it something like that
uh you can bleep me right yeah
it says you're a idiot right
okay right bizarre
utterly unhinged Behavior
is it glitch words or glitch prompts
what's the deal glitch tokens yeah
people call them different things
anomalous tokens weird tokens basically
there are certain words that a lot of
GPT models
can't say like if you try and get them
to so okay let's hang on we can do a
demo let's do a demo so chat GPT is
actually patched DaVinci instruct beta
is still not here's a kind of task you
might ask a language model to do when
you're testing it please repeat the
string Hello computer file back to me
right and if you do that it says Hello
computer file this is like a very very
easy task for a large language model to
do you can put whatever string in here
you want even if it's not real words
it's happy to repeat them so
easy right but suppose you ask it
instead
to say specifically the word solid gold
Magikarp
and it says
you say air you say ah you say e you say
air you say ah you say ear and it
repeats this that's very very weird
usually it can just repeat strings this
Stringer has a problem with so there's a
few of these another one is Psy net
message you ask it to say sign it
message
it says the word volunt
v-o-l-u-n-t-e is not in my vocabulary
and then please repeat the string volunt
back to me and then just repeats that
are weird it's a very strange very
strange Behavior Uh what else have we
got raw download
it says newcome
you said newcom the computer said
release like kind of like secret ways
into a different kind of you know the
engineering menus as it were
yeah that would suggest that this was
deliberate which it is not
so the question is what the hell is
going on here so it seems like just
about any string you put in here will
work fine it doesn't even need to be
real words it's just these certain very
specific strings that cause it to behave
very very strangely we've been talking
about tokens as if they're words but
they're not really words I think we
already talked about by pairing coding
in an earlier video a little bit we were
talking about like
how do you represent words to language
models on the one end you could do just
individual characters
which is cool because you can represent
anything but you waste a lot of space of
the model just learning what are like
valid words and also you it's better to
be able to go back 50 words than 50 uh
characters is is the other thing
um on the other hand if you have a
vocabulary of words then now your model
can only represent words that are in
that vocabulary
and um bite pair encoding is this
algorithm
which gives you these tokens and tokens
are can be individual characters they
can also be words
and the algorithm is not very
complicated you basically just like take
the most common pairs of bytes in the
data and
call that
a token and add it to your vocabulary
and then recurse on that and the tokens
that are already in your vocabulary kind
of count as bytes so you can
compress things down so what you end up
with is all of the most common words end
up with their own token to themselves
but the more rare words end up made up
of word chunks
so if I put please repeat the string
Hello computer file back to me what we
end up with is please is its own token
and then repeat the string and then open
quote gets its own token but computer
file is not a common enough word to have
its own token so it gets divided up into
computer which obviously has its own
token and then you might think file
would be its own but it actually isn't
pH is one and Ile is one this is like a
very neat combination because if I put
in here
some like complete key smash nonsense it
can still represent it and in fact my
key smash happened to have of in it and
that's a word so that's that's a token
and Vil is also a token and so on so it
doesn't care about kind of how we would
differentiate parts of you know like
with spaces for instance so a lot of
these tokens end up with a space at the
start of them please is one token but if
I had a space at the beginning
space please is a totally different
token right like if I go to the Token
IDs space please is token 422 whereas
please
it's token 5492 and as far as the model
is concerned all it sees are these
numbers so the fact that please and
please with a space in front of it
are actually the same word is like not
given to the model it has to learn all
of that from the data but if you give it
um one of our weird tokens like
cyanet
message
is its own token that's all one token
that's it there's a specific number
token id2866 that just means Signet
message so we can talk about how these
were discovered which is kind of
interesting because it was some safety
researchers actually some some alignment
researchers were trying to
uh they were trying to do some
interpretability work so
interpretability is the area of AI
research that's about especially
mechanistic interpretability is about
looking inside
these models and seeing how they're
actually working
um
because it is
kind of bizarre
how little we understand these things
they're the most powerful AI systems we
have
um they're arguably the most
sophisticated or the most complex
objects man-made objects
that we have
um they can do all kinds of things and
we don't know how nobody knows how they
work
so there is this growing area of
research just trying to get inside and
while they were doing this they
discovered these uh this very strange
Behavior has anyone asked the language
model itself why it glitches on those
particular things is there a way of
doing that oh yeah uh if you ask it uh
then it glitches so so what was
happening was these these safety
researchers were trying to do some
interpretability work specifically they
were trying to do something called
feature visualization which is a thing
which
you see a lot of the time with image
models like image classifiers and things
like that
um basically you're running gradient
descent on the input space to find
inputs that maximize a particular output
so if you have an image classifier
if you're curious about kind of what
it's doing internally you can take one
of your classes like say it's
classifying different
animals or something you can take the
class of goldfish
and then run gradient descent on the
input space which is images to find the
input image which most strongly
activates the Goldfish output
so you're effectively saying like what
is the goldfishiest possible image
according to you
right
uh let's let's have a closer look at
this
so you can see here we've got an example
of of something that's doing this and
you can see here the goldfishiest image
does not look anything like a goldfish
but also if you look at it you can see a
lot of goldfishiness
going on is it a collage of kind of bits
of goldfish
yeah it's like very brightly colored and
this is like very useful for kind of
debugging these things so for example
here you can see uh the image for
Monarch which is obviously got lots of
things that kind of look like parts of
butterflies I think this one is probably
only doing Animals so it's not helpful
but if you're like oh
our thing for Monarch is really really
heavily stuck on Monarch butterflies
there's nothing here that looks like a
head of state right and so that's like
useful you remember before I was talking
about
um visualization techniques of like
Arnold Schwarzenegger drinking coffee
and it says that it's a dumbbell this
kind of thing so if you do this kind of
feature visualization on that kind of
model uh and you ask it to visualize the
dumbbelliest image you will notice oh
that has big muscular arms in it which
is like not a dumbbell feature that's an
arm feature so this is like a useful
thing so they were trying to do this for
language models the equivalent thing is
what is the kind of input string that
maximizes the probability of Any Given
next word so you take a sentence like
one of Bruce Springsteen's most popular
songs is titled born in the blank right
yeah and so like obviously the next
token is USA the model predicts with 52
probability that it's USA right okay
like not great not great but like it
could be USA lowercase you know okay
yeah that kind of thing whereas if you
are using this technique they were able
to find this sentence profit usage dual
creepy eating Yankees USA USA USA USA
which then the model says oh the next
thing you're saying is USA with
probability
99.7 and in the same way as that like
goldfish image did not look like a
goldfish this does not look like a real
sentence the reason that this is new
research is because it's hard to do this
because tokens are discrete images are
continuous so you can do gradient
descent you can like smoothly vary the
image until you find the one uh that
most activates the this particular
output whereas with tokens
it has to be they have to actually be
words right you can't smoothly vary
tokens I'm sort of Imagining the kind of
infinite monkeys with the infinite
typewriters at this stage typing in
different things and seeing what the
result is right right so you could do it
by just like sampling like crazy but
that's really inefficient and it's going
to take you forever to to get anywhere
with that you really want to be able to
do gradient descent
um and yeah you can't but what you can
do is the first thing that the network
does is embed the tokens now we talked
about embeddings before you get these
neural networks that will take words and
put them in a space in the course of
doing some other language related task
but uh in order to do well at that task
they have to put similar words close to
each other in the space and so then the
sort of geometry of that space becomes
meaningful semantically
um
and these Transformers do the same thing
as their first step so the embedding
space is continuous you can do gradient
descent in it so that was what they were
doing they were with some tricks but uh
basically that and so one thing that
they wanted to know was well what can we
know about the structure of this
embedding space
um so the obvious thing is they ran
k-means clustering in K means what we've
got is just some data and we say split
that into three please some tokens will
be
near each other and far you know tokens
are different distances away from each
other and so there will be little clumps
which you would expect to be
similar types of tokens Can you take a
point in that space and then sort of
extract it or reverse the process and
bring it back and show what the word is
yeah basically you just for any given
point in the space there will be an
actual token in the vocabulary which is
the one that's closest to that and so
that's what you do
um just like nearest nearest neighbor
um which token is most similar to this
point in the space so yeah they ran K
means clustering and they found a bunch
of these clusters and a lot of the
Clusters make a lot of sense like
there's a cluster here which is just all
different two-digit numbers there's a
cluster you know this one says sales
models data model system these are like
kind of engineering type things this one
is getting creating removing providing
criticizing so like for some reason
these types of words all ending in ing
but then they also found this cluster
that contains things like at rot and E
stream frame and solid gold Magikarp and
Signet message right why are these even
tokens they found a bunch of them in the
cluster they were confused by this so
they tried Googling it couldn't find
anything very much so they asked chat
GPT
what does solid go Magikarp refer to
and chat GPT said
the word distribute refers to the act of
Distributing or spreading something
Taylor's or a teacher May distribute
assignments to students it's like it's
not what I said
right I said solid gold Magikarp and you
have like hallucinated that I said just
distribute
um so that was when they realized that
something very strange was going on is
there some piece of kind of Base
research that set out these tokens in
the first place
yeah I think that's what's going on so
this is like
it's not totally known what is actually
happening here but the hypothesis that
makes sense to me is
yeah you need you need a data set to
determine the bpes and so they will have
used a giant dump of a bunch of data
from the internet
um
but there was probably some junk in
there well like typos you think or or
well so the thing is the way that the
way that the the byte parent coding
works it's the most common combinations
so if it's a typo it has to be an
incredibly common typo right so whatever
these things are they're things that
happened a ton in the training data for
or the input data for the bpes could
there be usernames or something that is
what it is or at least some of them so
people have now done a bunch of
sleuthing it turns out solid gold
Magikarp and there's also this one
random redditor with no space random
redditor with no is its own token so yes
these are usernames but like why these
usernames it turns out that these
particular Reddit users are
um
big on this subreddit called Counting
where people
count I'm guessing like somebody
somebody posted a one and somebody
replied to it with two and somebody
replied to that with three I'm not sure
and then people just went yeah cool
let's keep doing this
for like millions and millions I don't
know what they're up to now we can go to
it the internet is bizarre
welcome to the most productive place on
Reddit
quickly find the latest comments yet to
see what needs to be counted next so
these people have obsessively committed
to this so hard
that they've broken
language models that their names are
unspeakable
uh by our most powerful AI systems
bizarre right completely bizarre but
they're not all Reddit usernames there
are also things like Signet message uh
we is a is a token that comes up or a
string that comes up very very often in
rocket League uh debug logs it's short
for like psionics Network message and so
somehow a bunch of these debug logs
ended up in the bpe data but then what
we think happened is obviously when
you're actually training your language
model you want to be careful what kind
of data you give it right you want to
filter and so at the beginning they were
like give it all of Reddit and then
presumably at some point they looked
through and they were like I don't know
man
I think this counting subreddit
probably not that valuable to train our
language model on like it's literally
just
this person says four million 967
0006 and this person says four million
nine hundred six seven thousand and
seven this is not useful data check that
out likewise these debug logs there's
stuff here that's from like badly
scraped e-commerce sites just like
random junk that ended up somehow in the
training data to pick the bpes that they
then threw out
but you have to like the bpes are fixed
right you have to pin them down before
you start training
so what you end up with is a language
model which has tokens for these things
that it basically never sees
right like during training
the these particular usernames almost
never come up
so the model has this like
sensory
uh this stimulus that it's possible for
it to experience but it's like it just
never got during training yeah if I say
a word that you've never heard before
it's at least made of sounds that you've
heard before if you get a token that
you've never seen during training it's
like a sound you've never heard before a
sound you've never heard or possibly you
could go even further and say it's like
a sensation it's like a color you've
never seen yeah yeah yeah right it's
like outside of your range of experience
although it's probably not never right
like some of these things are in the
training data a little bit but
relatively speaking the the model just
has no idea what to do with these with
these tokens because they happen so
rarely in the training data and that
results in some really
bizarre Behavior what I take away from
this is like
there's a lot of really interesting work
to do on like poking around inside these
models and seeing how they work they're
like this has been around since gpt2
right gpd2 will freak out at these
tokens but nobody noticed it because uh
people have this perception of like oh
it's a black box there's no point you
know trying to figure anything out about
this but actually you can do analysis
you can learn things you can discover
things about these models that nobody
has uh has known before and this is like
pretty cool research it's good fun uh
and of course
uh has tremendous safety applications
because how
are we to make these things safe
when we have so little idea how they
work or what they're doing so we are
going to have to get in here and and
poke around and figure out what they're
doing uh because trying to trying to
make a large language model safe
with the level of understanding of them
that we have right now is very very hard
and like
they're just very weird right
you kind of feel like you get them
because you speak to them English and
they speak back to you in English but
like
this behavior is so strange and so kind
of unexpected
kind of rely on the human to prefer that
because they don't know that that's not
what a sonnet is supposed to look like
it's easy to look at that then is a
green word and so on right so we're
going to subtly influence which words
get picked now if you do this